Go ahead. What's the other question?
>> So, um I I wasn't on this live debating,
but I I was listening to, you know, they
make claims all over Tik Tok, and
somebody was saying, "If Jesus is
Yahweh, why does he say he came in his
father's name?"
>> How many persons you believe are Yahweh?
>> Father, Son, and Spirit.
>> So, do you want Jesus to come
independently apart from the father and
do things on his own initiative?
No.
>> So when Jesus says he comes in his
father's name, meaning authorized by the
father, how does that disprove him being
Yahweh, if father and son, holy spirit
are one and they possess the same
nature? Because they're one, they can
only act in perfect union and harmony
with one another.
>> Okay.
Yeah, that would have been a shoot.
>> So if you come in your father's name,
let's say what's your last name? I'm a
junior already as it is. It's a Kent.
>> So what's your name?
>> Kente. And
>> your dad is Kente.
>> Yeah.
>> So if you come in your father's name
authority, does that make you less a
Kente, less a less human than your
father?
>> Nah.
>> Are you sure?
>> Positive.
>> You positive?
>> So Kente Senior, Kente Jr. So we got two
Kentes, two Hogans, right? Yeah.
>> And then your father says, "Son, I want
you to go out there and relay this
message to whatever group." You say,
"Look, I've come in my father's name.
He's authorized me to speak on his
behalf." So that means
>> I get it.
>> And he can't be a kinte and he can't be
a Hogan. He's a kintan. No one need to
send him in his name.
>> I get it. It's almost like uh like when
when somebody's last name is powerful
and they say uh the third and the fourth
and the fifth and each generation.
>> Not even even last name. You go with
Kinte Senior, Kente the Junior and then
you're going to bring Kente the third.
Let's say there's three.
>> That's my son right now. He's the third.
>> How ironic.
>> So Kente Hogan Kente Hogan Jr. Kente
Hogan the third.
>> Yep. That means now when you send your
son to do something on your behalf and
he says hey Kinte sent me in his name
then who are you? I'm Kinte. How the
hell can you be Kinte if you're sent by
Kinte?
>> And then the Kinte sent you. Is he
human? Yeah. So if he sent you then
you're less human than him because if
you're fully human no one would send you
and you'd be owning your kinte. Get it?
Kinte.
>> Yeah it makes sense.
>> How old are you?
>> 25. God bless. How's your son?
>> Seven months.
>> God bless. Preserve your family. Raise
him in the fear and love of Jesus
Christ.
>> Amen. Man, we learning a lot from you.
We were just doing a Sunday Bible study
on
>> But I'm not
>> I'm old I'm I'm almost as old as your
grandfather. Or maybe I'm as old as
Kinte Senior.
>> Yeah, my dad's 49.
>> Damn. I'm older than him.
>> So I'm not as patient as used to be. So
when they say how can Jesus be Yahweh if
he comes in his father's name let me
think hm oh oh because Jesus is not the
only person who's Yahweh father is God
son is God spirit is God they're the
same God have the same nature they bear
the same name so when Jesus says I came
on my father's name it's simply to show
them I didn't come on my own initiative
doing my own thing because I'm not that
kind of son I'm the son who only and
always works in perfect union with the
father and does what pleases
and he does whatever I ask cuz that's
why they're one god because they work in
perfect union.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. You don't believe me? Ask the
kintes. There's three of them.
>> They're all fully human. They have the
same nature. They have the same name.
They're not the same person. And one
kint can send the other kint to talk to
the third kinte. So kint s can say,
"Hey, kint junior kint. I love him." Hey
k the third. Kente Senior tells you he
loves you. Well, what about you, Kente
Jr.? All of you, too. Now, Kente Jr.,
tell Kinte Sor that Kente Third loves
him, too. That's a lot of Kint to keep
up with.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. It's crazy, man. It was that It's
crazy how simple the answer is, but you
can over complicated if you think too
hard. Like,
>> exactly, bro. Keep it simple, Saint. You
know the word kiss, they used to use it
for computer. Keep it simple, stupid. So
now we say keep it simple saint. The
word kiss keep it simple stupid but now
we say keep it simple saint.
>> Yeah.
>> Any other question?
>> Um this it's it's not much of a question
but it's kind Yeah, it is a question.
How do you explain to somebody like
because you can explain to people that
Jesus is God, but it's hard for them to
relay that he's not the father when
okay, you show them in the Old Testament
that obviously he's God. They understand
that he's God, but
for some reason they have a problem with
him being the father and not the and I
mean not him not being the father and
being the son.
>> So is he talking to himself when he
says, "Father, the hour has come.
glorify your son that your son may
glorify you. How's that work?
>> That's crazy, man. I I I said that to a
modalist once,
man. And they said, uh, they said,
"Yeah, when I I showed them John 16."
Um,
>> so then, yeah. So, what do you mean?
It's crazy to think he is the father
when he's speaking of the father and
saying, "The father sent me
>> and the father's in me and I am the
father. We are one." That makes no sense
if he's the father. So, I don't know if
they say, "Well, that's human nature."
Sorry. Natures don't speak. Persons do.
Yeah, especially I um I brought up the
verse where he said when the Holy Spirit
comes, he won't speak of himself, but he
whatever he hears, that's shall he
speak. And I said, "So who hear from
who?" And they said himself. And I I
just like I'm like, "Bro, it can't be
that stupid."
>> And you know what you say? say you just
blasphe Jesus because you either now say
he's the world's worst communicator
because he's sending himself or he's a
liar because he gave you an impression
the spirit is not him. He's going to
hear from him but he's lying because
it's actually him. So either way you
>> Yeah. When he said he hears from
himself, I was like bro like I just got
out of there.
>> Sorry, man. Homie don't play that. You
just blasphe.
>> Why is it blasphemy? Because you're
saying Jesus either is a terrible
communicator because he clearly refers
to the spirit as being sent by the
father in him and then hearing from the
father and him. So they're not the same.
But you're saying they are. But the way
Jesus says it leaves me with the
impression spirit is not him. So either
he doesn't know how to communicate or
he's lying because it's really him but
he told me it's not really him. He's
going to hear from himself but it's not
really someone else that hears from him.
Even though if I tell you, hey, I'm
going to send someone and he's only
going to speak what he hears, the clear
impression is that someone is not me and
he's hearing from me. So, he's either a
liar or he's a terrible communicator.
Either way, you've blasphemed God.
>> And he says he will not speak of
himself. But if that's him, then he is
speaking of himself.
>> Yep. That's what I'm saying. You make
him a liar or a terrible communicator,
bro.
>> Yeah.
>> That's crazy, man. I don't know where
people
>> It's like saying people derive that.
It's like saying, "Hey, Kinte sent me to
speak." But ain't you Kinte? Yeah. But
ain't you your father? No. Wait, wait,
wait. You said Kinte sent you to speak.
Yeah. But you're Kinte. Yeah. So then
you sent yourself and you're speaking on
your behalf. No, he sent me. Who? Kinte.
But who are you? Kinte. So Kinte sent
Kinte. Yeah. So are you Kinte? No. Then
you said you are. Yes. Because I'm not
that Kinte who sent me. Oh, so you are
Kinte. Yeah. So you send yourself. No.
Because I'm not that Kinte.
>> I think Jesus can be over complicating
to like the average person because some
people a lot of people are not like
literate like when it comes to reading.
>> No, it's not literate, brother. It's
common sense. If Jesus says the father
sent me, I only speak what the father
tells me. Even someone as dumb as
Muhammad can get it.
No, it's not complicated. Who
complicates it? Satan, demons, and their
agents, their vessels,
humans who don't want God to be God as
God has revealed himself and want to
make God into something he's not. That's
why it gets complicated. Anyone reading
the New Testament will never walk away
with Jesus being the father or the Holy
Spirit. Impossible.
>> Yeah, it's super. It's crazy. It's so
many. It's it's starting to be too many
oneness. Like too many oneness people
everywhere.
>> And you know why? Because they have to
be trained by a pervert who perverts the
Bible because he's influenced by Satan
and sin to misread these passages
because the plain reading. If you give
the New Testament to your child, let's
give it to him when he's old enough to
read, he will never walk away. Daddy,
Jesus is the father and he speaks to
himself.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. And I think people don't like the
trinity because it came from the
Catholic church or like the whatever the
ancient church is, but USA Catholic
church most people. So they kind of
their their hatred for the Catholic
Church makes them try to derive
something separate from what they teach.
>> Yep. Well, yeah. Well, anyway, brother,
you know how to refute them now, right?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. I got it.
>> I don't care what Kente Senior said
about you. And hopefully Kente be okay
with Kent.
Brother.
>> All right.
>> God bless you, brother.
My computer. It's not charging. I wonder
why. Pray. I guess it shows the charging
is not